There we go.
Hello everybody.
Hello, hello.
Why is it so quiet?
I clicked out again.
That's why.
Hold on, I forgot to...
It took me a little minute.
Hold on.
It took me a second because I...
Went to go make some tea.
And I was getting my tea because it's in my cabinet.
And I heard a cat outside.
And I was like, kitty.
And I opened the door a little bit.
I was like, kitty.
And I see the cat run by.
And actually, this cat I saw yesterday.
And I saw this cat yesterday because Paz started...
So, Paz sometimes... I guess I have a lot of strays around the maid cafe.
And yesterday,
Paz...
So, Paz sometimes sees the strays.
And will like, yell at them from the window.
And so that's what she did yesterday.
She was just like...
And I was really upset.
And then I saw this cat again.
And I'm like, oh my gosh.
She's just running around, this little kitten.
And I kind of want her, but...
I don't think Paz likes her very much.
Anyway, sorry.
That just happened, so...
It's in my brain.
It's on my brain.
Anyway, welcome!
Thank you!
Yeah, Paz does not want her.
No.
It's funny too, because Paz and Butaro...
I feel have grown even closer lately.
Where like, you know...
Where it's like...
They have recently started cuddling with each other.
Like sleeping...
Not cuddling, but they sleep next to each other recently.
And I'm like, oh my gosh.
It's only been a year and they are finally more friends.
Can't stay.
Oh no, Brandon!
I hope you feel better.
That's tough.
But thanks for the superchat.
Thanks for dropping by.
Rest up.
Using each other as pillows.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So...
Yeah, they've been getting closer.
And I feel lately even Paz has started to like me a bit more.
Because, you know, it's been almost a year since I've had her.
But only recently has she really been purring more often.
She took a really long time to kind of super warm up.
But now I feel that she has.
Utaro finally learned the required phrases to take her to the love box.
Yeah, I moved up from dislike to acceptable.
Yeah, I give her lots of love.
All the time.
Anytime I see her...
Oh my gosh, one of my favorite things about her...
Sorry, now I'm talking about my cat.
But every time I see her...
She'll like do a little...
She does like little chirpy types of meows.
And I can see her bottom teeth.
Cats have really small bottom teeth.
And it's so cute.
Is Paz still farting?
Sometimes.
I actually got her a new food just the other day.
And she pooped solids.
But it was like the longest poop I've ever seen.
It was probably like six inches of just straight poop.
I was like, whoa.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Impressive.
It was pretty.
I was like, dang.
I was so shocked.
That actually happened today.
Where I was like, whoa.
I was like, whoa.
I almost wanted to take a picture of it.
It was just...
I've never seen anything...
Like it before.
I was like, whoa.
That's such a long poop.
Do it next time.
I wasn't prepared.
I heard her in the litter box and I turned and watched.
Because, you know, I like to make sure that my cats are going properly.
Because, you know, that's a sign of if they're not going to the bathroom.
It's a sign, you know, of something wrong.
So I like...
I just watched my cat's poop.
And I watched this.
I was like, whoa.
And then she covered it up while I was like stun-walked.
Because she's, you know, polite.
And she covers her poop.
Whereas Butaro is a foul sub-beast.
He doesn't even do that.
What have I stepped into here?
Six inches of what?
Some would say that's average, no?
Looking quite dorky today.
Oh my gosh.
Mika's Fries.
I haven't seen you in so long.
Hi.
Welcome back.
DMC Netflix tomorrow.
Do I have to get Netflix?
I don't want to.
But I got Apple TV for severance.
Maybe I'll...
Is it gonna be a bingeable series?
Can I binge it and then cancel, I wonder.
I'd wait until you're done with games.
You know what?
True.
I think I'll wait until I'm done.
And also once I've heard what people...
But even if people say something, usually I still want to watch it.
Even if people say it's really, really bad.
Lord Grosses, thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Thank you, thank you.
Because you know, some people can be like...
I feel sometimes...
In a crowd, if a majority is overly critical...
Then other people kind of adopt that belief.
Or they go in very like...
Like already...
They're already in it for a bad time.
Bandwagoning.
Yeah, yeah, I think that's a good way to put it.
The herd mindset.
So...
Pessimistic?
Maybe.
Though, I understand why people often are pessimistic about...
About stuff.
Oh my gosh!
Speaking of pessimism...
Thank you, thanks for the gifted.
I...
I almost tweeted.
I almost tweeted yesterday.
I was about to say...
Because I can't watch the Switch 2 Direct...
Hollow Knight, what's it called?
What's the new one?
Silksong.
Yeah, Silksong will be announced.
You're welcome.
In the same way that I did for Tomodachi Life.
But I was just like...
Nah, I'm not gonna say that.
I should have done it!
But I was thinking...
I was like...
Nah, just whatever.
That would have been crazy.
I totally thought it though.
You have to believe me.
Nothing new shown.
But they showed a new date.
That's new.
They showed the year.
But yeah, I did watch the...
The...
The Direct.
Earlier.
So that was fun.
Today is my birthday!
Could I get a very special happy birthday from the cutest guy's maid?
Your boy, Gaster.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, your boy, Gaster.
Happy birthday!
Can you also miss all future Directs for prosperity?
Right?
But it feels like between last week and this week, many, many people are quite pleased.
So that's always a good thing, huh?
I got my number one The Jorker Dead Society badge.
I also have that.
Whoa, that was weird.
What was weird?
What happened?
Sorry, that's not what was weird.
That is my controller disconnecting because I'm yapping.
$4.50 for Switch 2 though.
Yeah, the pricing...
is very pain.
Save predictions for Twin Snakes on Switch 2?
Oh my gosh, wait.
Actually though, because we're getting GameCube games.
I didn't think about that.
It could actually happen.
Oh my gosh.
What controller am I using?
It's the Bitdo, 8Bitdo controller.
Yeah, yeah, I always use this one.
But also, it's my friend Marcelo's birthday.
The other day, can you please sing him the MGS5 happy birthday?
Of course, Winter Cedar.
Happy birthday, congratulations.
Happy birthday, with salutations.
Happy birthday, may your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you, Marcelo!
Happy birthday!
Cool, cool, cool.
They have good controllers.
I have a couple of theirs.
Yeah, I really like this one.
If you're ever wanting a new controller that works for your computer.
You plan to play DMC4 reboot?
What is... DMC Devil May Cry?
Hashtag ad?
No.
This is my own personal recommendation.
Dropping offerings so one day my childhood video games get a revamp, remake someday.
Thank you for the offerings.
Product not guaranteed.
8BitDo controllers are the best, never going back.
Yeah, I really do like their controllers.
And it's pink.
So it's cute.
OK-ish time.
Waste turbo overall, it fell short.
DMC is a good game, but a bad Devil May Cry.
So it's...
Survival.
It's Metal Gear Survive.
I said survival, sorry.
Metal Gear Survive.
What type?
Mine is a wireless one.
Can my goat Kasane Teto get a late happy birthday?
Was it her birthday really?
That's one way to put it.
Did you get my direct related ping on the blue sky?
Sorry Nicholas, I am bad at checking blue sky.
I'm really bad.
So, I'm sorry though.
But yeah, I've yapped enough, I've yapped enough.
Shall we start?
So we are back to...
We are back to Dante.
Dante, Dante, Dante.
I'm going to Japan for the first time.
Do you want me to pick you up anything?
Jelly, jelly, jelly, please.
Side topic 2.
When I was playing a game hunting demons last night, I suddenly heard a ghastly...
Wait, what?
Real?
Oh, turned out the debut stream had randomly started playing during your mic test in the background window.
You're confirmed to be scary.
I am.
I told you all.
Some people like the DMC Reboot's music.
Can you blame them with lyrics like...
Ready, set, zombie, fist fight.
I don't know.
I don't think anything can top this song.
But I could be wrong.
You know?
Is it time?
Is it time for...
For fancy...
William Dante fancy pants?
Are you excited for the Nintendo Switch 2?
I think so.
It's hard to say.
There's not much that has been announced that's only for the Switch 2 that I'm like, gotta have it.
You know?
I'm not a super Mario Kart head.
I miss Ducky.
He'll come back, maybe.
He's going indie, I think I heard.
Celebrating my two months and my birthday.
Just for me!
I will sing a happy birthday and then we'll start.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday just for me.
Happy birthday!
OK.
I think I'll try it.
Where are we at?
Mission.
Drive down the dragon that spreads its wickedness through the forest.
OK, that sounds...
I don't think we watched the cutscene for this mission yet.
So...
Is that red my DT?
Oh good, all these carried over.
It did say that it would, didn't it?
Oh, we can get more porb!
There is no cutscene.
There wasn't?
Porb.
Dante's DT is red.
I think...
Oh, I've used that before.
I need to get...Oh, is charge shot good with Dante?
I didn't really use it so much, did I, before?
I tried and I sucked at it.
Not as good as Nero?
Always stinger.
So true!
So, so true.
We got that.
Oh, I don't have enough.
Big Mac!
Thanks for the gift!
Get more orbs!
Look at all those surrounding him.
Gosh.
Let me stop.
OK.
I'm sorry, I'm just going through everything again.
Right now I think we are OK.
ABS, always be stinger.
I love this music.
OK.
Power of the forest master is preventing you from escaping.
What's this sound?
OK.
Oh!
Oh no, we are back here.
Big fan of...you are...well, it is my birthday today!
Yes, me, Pedro Pascal.
From the hit series, The Mandalorian and The Last of Us.
Can you wish me a quick happy birthday?
Stay awesome, you lovely lady.
I don't think this is identity theft, right?
I have motivation.
Wait, that's so good.
Dante's ET is red, Nero's is blue.
I have motivation.
How about you?
Happy birthday, Pedro Pascal.
Happy birthday to you.
Gosh, rough weather we have here.
Inside.
It's nasty out.
OK, so now we actually have to go this way.
Do I go down?
Oh, more.
DMC4 today, Framinto and the DMC anime tomorrow.
DMC fans are eating well this week.
It wasn't even planned either.
The purple fogs are teleporters?
Oh, they are?
Oh, I thought it was just a wall.
Is this a maze?
Oh my gosh, I forgot that we look like that for a second.
I can't.
Who's the gal that 100% all...
All robs.
That's the girl, Minfanta.
Wasn't this the exit?
Oh, well...
Oh no, we are back here.
I could go down.
Hold on.
What does this one take me to then?
Does this rain destroy the bitrate?
I'm curious.
Oh, we are back here.
OK.
A little?
Sorry about that.
OK, I definitely think we have to go down then.
Wait, or I went... Wait.
I think I went this way and then it teleported me.
Oh my gosh, I just noticed that it's all collapsed.
Because it happened last time, yeah.
OK, let's go.
Wait.
Don't come at me like that.
Gross, nasty.
I hear someone laughing.
Who's laughing at me?
Oh, there's more.
There's more.
I'm going to teleport.
Wait, can I go through?
Point and laugh.
Point and laugh at the VTuber.
Oh, I can't tell where I'm at at all.
No 100% roar for me.
Just kidding.
Oh wait, I think I kind of remember this area.
Yes, I remember this area.
She's laughing at me.
All sexy like.
Oh, what the hell?
Damn.
Oh,
you're still alive?
I
just gave him one shot.
Point blank to the face, baby.
Where is this lady at?
Stop, she's so sexy.
Oh, can I not activate this since I don't have the spooky hand?
Oh, I can.
Interesting.
Find the sexy lady.
I thought we killed her.
She's such a sore loser.
No, I was so close.
Ok, I give up.
When I get here, she sounds closer, but...
Oh, is it because... Am I supposed to go over there, lady?
I love finding these little eggs.
It's like Easter.
Oh, she did run away.
Ok, I'll go in.
Lady?
Oh.
Seems like we are in the right direction.
Otherwise it wouldn't stop us.
Where are you?
Oh, I see you.
Don't get up.
Get your balls now.
Return to IA.
Blast off.
IA.
Oh, my robes over here.
I didn't get them in time.
The more robes, the more plorbs, everybody.
It's very important.
IA.
Are you guys having a good Wednesday?
It's hump day.
Hi,
Mito.
Hello.
Oh, why did it change like that?
What do you mean you are now?
That's pretty nice.
That's good.
No, because I'm working.
Boo.
Oh, I hear her again.
We are close.
Is this still here?
Oh, my gosh.
It is.
What is it?
Oh, wait.
We did this one.
That's right.
I completed it.
I was like, why isn't it red?
Because I'm so good.
Oh, wait.
No.
Oh, gosh.
Please.
Wait, how am I supposed to beat you guys without the grabby grab?
Oh, my God.
Wait, I'd rather... I don't want to.
I don't want to.
Yes.
Ouchie.
Gun.
Nice.
Easy peasy.
Tricks.
Nice.
Lady.
Lady, my lady.
Not that lady, but other...
Other lady.
I hear you laughing.
Which way do I go?
Do I go inside or do I go to the purple?
Hey, what?
Then there's also this purple.
Where does that lead to?
Use your lady detection senses.
You can hear how stuffy my nose is.
Because of my allergies.
How is that cute?
Wait, look at this.
Look at this nerd.
He's probably... Oh, my gosh.
This is the worst outfit to wear in the rain.
He's like soaked and it's probably dripping and just heavy.
Why did I... Why?
Why?
Give me my money.
It's stuck down there.
No, my money!
Why?
Ouch.
You know what?
Dang it, I hate this area.
I hate this area.
Yeah.
Oh no!
Please come back!
We missed her.
I have a feeling I go into the one underneath.
Maybe.
Again?
Seriously?
Maybe not.
Where am I?
Wait, I'm lost.
Oh, here we are.
Where are you?
No, no, no!
Turn around!
Nice!
Get him!
No!
Tricks!
Who are you?
Which do you guys think?
This way or down here?
Oh, Ebony Ivory!
Wait, how do I...
There we go.
Ebony Ivory.
This way.
Whatever I think.
I think... I'm gonna try this way then.
She's laughing.
Oh, dang it.
She's laughing here.
Oh, she's laughing.
She's laughing.
She thinks it's really funny.
I told the best joke ever.
She's into me.
Maybe not.
She's laughing at the idea.
Dang it.
Am I supposed to get back to her or...
Wait, I can do this now because I'm...
Oh my God!
I can do this one now.
I don't feel like it though.
Sorry.
Guys...
Is anyone else feeling lazy today?
Try with Sword Master.
Sword Master.
It's remembering all the combos.
We're so close though.
Blade!
Circle in the air.
Square, circle.
This one?
She's so loud.
Loud lady.
Oh, but we can't do this one.
Oh wait, this...Oh wait.
This is just the other one.
What did this one go to again?
I remember we opened up the path down there though.
Maybe I go that way instead.
I think... Do I not go down?
Do I not go through here instead?
I feel like I go through here.
Let me see.
Oh, it's not raining here.
Oh, hello.
What?
Oh my goodness.
You, chill out.
Oh, you're both dead.
Quit your whining.
The music is kind of funny here.
Do I have to do this again?
Oh wait, because didn't I do this to get to the area where the lady is at?
Those who treat her unkindly will fall into darkness.
Okay, so I go... Wait, hold on.
Let me read it.
Those who do not wish for darkness should seek the light.
Okay, so I just follow...
the shadow...
and also collect robes.
Okay, so we go this way.
If you go the wrong way once, you can get a Bloor fragment.
Is that...
Is that real?
How many Bloor fragments do I have right now?
2 out of 4.
It is true?
Chat, is this real?
It's real.
Try it.
Really?
Well, we've only gone one way.
Let's try it.
I was supposed to fill your dark zone with light.
Oh my goodness, stop.
I'm trying to stinger you.
Please.
I'm trying to get close to you.
Why
do...
Everytime...
You are near...
Just like me...
I long to be...
Close to you...
That's it?
Bloor!
Bloor fragment at the top far right wall.
Here?
There really is one!
I don't think I can...
Can I not get it though?
Because I don't have a grabby grab.
Oh no!
DT can triple jump.
Thank you!
Nice!
Oh my gosh, again?
I'm running!
Run away!
So it is the same.
What's this purple one?
If you want to leave this forest, do not fall into darkness, but rather treat her kindly to proceed.
Where there is light, there must be shadow, but shadow leads only to darkness.
And then this probably says the same thing though.
So we go back from where we came.
Bamboo!
Welcome to bamboo ship!
Okay.
Is there a third one now?
This.
Am I going the right way?
Hold on.
Thanks for telling me about the blower fragment you guys.
I really appreciate it.
It's this way right?
If you get it wrong they add more hints.
Oh that's so cute!
That's so nice actually.
She's laughing.
Fifty...Wait!
30,000!
I can get one!
I wish I could buy another blower.
Oh I can only get one more blower.
Am I kind of in the way?
Let me shrink down just a tiny bit.
Okay.
Very good DT time.
I'm here for...Oh my gosh I'm all dressed up for the date you guys.
This is the perfect outfit to pick actually.
Are we going to use brother's sword to close the game?
She's...He just shakes his head.
She's spitting her seed.
I don't want...Yeah, kick him back into the woods.
This is an invasive species.
Good!
Dark souls are the best.
But the kindest fate I offer is to unify and spend eternity with a child of mine.
Sweet child of mine.
And slurp him up like a little spaghetti.
He looks so stupid.
Interesting.
Sexy lady, where'd you go?
I don't know how I dodged that, but I am so good.
Damn.
Oh no, she's going to spit.
Oh come on, I thought I got it.
Can I get her?
Get her sack.
Gross.
She's so gross.
Let me get that thing real quick.
Alright.
Hit the sack.
I did not avoid it this time.
Oh no, please, please let me...
Please, let me get a hit, please.
Oh my god, please.
Please, oh my god.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, that did like nothing.
I wish I could... Wait, is it because I'm sword master?
How do I... Wait, oh here we go.
Okay, hold on, I'm remembering.
Sorry guys.
There we go.
Circle mid-area.
Oh my god.
Okay, she's just spamming the same attack over and
over.
What are you doing?
No.
Oh
my god, she just took that guy out.
Woop.
Save it.
No, please.
My health.
She's strong.
Oh my gosh, she's strong.
I'm healing, I'm healing.
Oh my gosh, how do I avoid?
I'm so dead.
No, I'll just do it again.
I'll just redo it.
But I wasted a lot of health, I feel.
Not remembering the mid-air attack.
Abandon all hope.
Trickster dash for dodge.
That could work.
Did it save my stuff?
No, we lost all of my DT.
I'm gonna have to re-get it back.
Try to upgrade swordmaster and trickster.
I'm pretty sure I have both of them at max.
Or at least, I can't afford the max I think of swordmaster.
Also gonna try... Is gunslinger any good in this fight too?
Maybe if I use that one.
Wait, what was it?
Hold on.
Hold on, I gotta look up.
Wait, hold on.
Systems maybe?
Not options.
I don't remember how to do the dodge.
It's under skills?
Abilities?
Side roll?
RB?
Oh, I was doing RT.
And A.
Okay.
RBA.
So I lock on and A.
Okay.
Maybe that's what I was doing earlier.
Or trickster circle.
Yeah.
But I still wanted to know how to do it just in case I wasn't switched.
RB.
Okay.
Nasty!
She spit another thing or not?
Oh, come on!
Come on!
I'm not even... Come on!
Dante!
There we go.
Woo!
Oh, that worked actually.
Oh, wait!
Oh, I did it though!
Yay!
Oh, I didn't press A!
I did like...
Did
I kill this thing?
Oh, no I didn't.
Yeah!
Take it down!
Oh, if only I had DT'd!
Ouch!
Okay.
Nice!
Come
on!
Just a little bit!
There we go!
Did we get to absorb her power?
One down.
This does not fit the look at all.
Oh my gosh!
She looks so cool!
I was drinking my tea.
Yeah!
He's kicking!
He's punching!
Oh my gosh!
He's stacking!
Jenga!
Two to go.
Okay.
Nice!
Gilgamesh!
A devilish weapon that absorbs organic material and transforms it to steel.
This weapon is capable of creating powerful impacts.
Damn!
Why?
Any part of this combo can be charged by holding down.
Girugamish!
Alright, he had to change swords.
Yup!
And now we can escape.
Yippee!
Oh!
Hold on!
Let me get my money.
My rewards.
Wowee!
My rewards, exactly!
My rewards!
And I didn't even need to heal in that fight.
Let's go baby!
Though I spent all of it on the plorbs.
So I would like to get a little bit more back.
Thank you!
Okey dokey!
I guess we just go from...
Well, we can't go this way.
Well, not us.
Wow!
Man!
Gravity!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
Gaming go!
Movies!
Welcome to the membership!
Thank you!
She is literally gaming.
I'm gaming.
I'm literally playing a game.
Yay!
Nice job on that boss.
I'm impressed with the evolution of your gaming skill.
Really?
Thanks!
Easy!
C.
C for C!
I told you I can do it!
C!
Mission.
Get through as quickly as possible.
Okey, I'm going to have to remember how to get home.
Okey, as quickly as possible.
My therapist said that Monocle Dante wasn't real.
My Oshi can dodge!
I'm so proud!
Sign me up for Dark Souls, baby!
I'll play that new not-Bloodborne game.
Okey, so far there is not a timer.
What in the world is that?
That thing is ugly as hell!
It reminds me of those...
Do you guys know...
I won't be greedy.
Do you guys know the...
In Legend of Zelda, like Link's Awakening, there is the little guys that come from the sand.
I'm not very fast, so...
Oh my Stinger!
I miss you, Stinger!
The Octor... I don't think it's the Octoroks.
They don't shoot.
These things are nasty.
They come from the ground and they look just like these guys.
How do I get out of here?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my goodness.
Did I kill him?
Or...
I don't know.
I think I missed my opportunity with the other guy.
That's kind of stinky.
No!
Oh my gosh.
I'm going to switch back for this.
I need to be faster.
I need to be faster here.
There we go.
These guys are so stinky.
Holy moly.
Wait, there is more?
Where?
Oh my gosh.
There is more.
No!
Please leave me alone.
Oh no, it's you.
Ouch,
ouch, ouch.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
I hate you.
I hate you already.
No, dodge, dodge, dodge, please.
Dodge, dodge, dodge.
I'm just gonna...
Get out of my face, please.
So bad, those dark souls.
Maybe I spoke too soon.
Maybe I got a little overly confident.
Maybe I got a little...
I'm grabbing some health while we can.
I don't remember how to get out of here.
No, I've run through these forest so much.
I don't know which way.
Give me more green.
Thank you.
Ok, that should be good.
Minto eating her words?
Check the map.
I don't think that's the map actually.
We are trying to get to there, right?
Oh, so I am...
Wait.
Yeah, we are trying to get to there.
That's it, right?
No, that's...
To the castle?
Wait.
Which is the exit?
I didn't know you could kill that thing.
I've played this game 10 times.
What?
Wait.
You are leaving the forest?
Yeah, but I can't tell which way is the forest.
Wait, forest entrance.
Ok, ok.
So, yes, I am going...
Wait, but can I get through here?
Can I get through that area?
Oh, shoot.
Wait, I must...
Be able to.
Did you see Wonderfest?
They are making figures of Naked Snake from Snake Eater and Raiden from MGS4.
I did see that!
I saw the news.
I can't believe tomorrow is your last day.
I'll miss you, boss.
What news?
No!
You read wrong!
Ok.
Wait, hold on.
I'm checking the map.
Ok.
I think we are going the correct direction.
I think we are going...
The right way.
Who's in here?
You guys.
Ouch!
Oh my gosh, they spit?
Since when?
Since when do you spit?
Where are you?
Oh, shoot.
Are
you dead?
Making sure I get my glory.
My fame and glory.
Don't believe him.
He's a spy.
Wait, who am I believing?
Who am I to believe?
What am I not trusting?
What's going on?
What are you guys talking about?
Ok.
Stop!
These guys are so obsessed with me.
They're like Dante.
It's got them really sick out, but...
I'm going the right way, right?
Yep.
And then we go...
We go upwards.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Sunny day, oh sunny day.
What are we going to fight in here, I wonder?
Puppets!
Oh my goodness, ouch!
Stop
doing...
Go away!
Ouchie, ouchie, ouchie.
You know what?
Screw it.
I don't want to deal with your stinky anymore.
Two guys.
At least these guys give me health.
That's kind of nice.
Ok.
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Gravity, thank you for the 20 gets a dick!
No grabby arm on Dante, I know it's so sad.
It's like so sad actually.
Do these guys like never unspawn?
It's kind of nice if they do.
Ok, we go...
That seems to be the case.
Breakdown!
They don't stop coming, they don't stop coming, they don't stop coming.
But they can't come on the cliff.
Okie dokie.
Hello?
Rorb statue.
Nice.
A little treasure trove in here.
Take that and that and that and that.
Did we do this one?
Sacred mission.
Royal blocker.
Successfully execute a royal block 5 times.
I think I'm good.
A royal block?
You mean I actually have to use royal guard?
You mean I actually have to play the game to it's full potential?
What is that?
Bright?
I saw something glowing over here.
Vital star.
It's gonna be a whole stream?
Surely.
What a nice day.
Why is it starting to get rainy again?
I'm just making sure...
Okay.
Okay, I'm leaving.
I'm getting out of here.
What's that?
Why are there...
Oh, I thought that was a carpet.
Quickly Dante.
Oh yeah, that was the mission wasn't it?
Get out of here as quick as possible.
Oops.
They didn't give me a timer so...
Quick is subjective, no?
That's a nice score by Dusei.
So myself, SPA.
More like SUPA.
If I could, I think I'd get the letter P. That's my stylish point.
Nice.
Costume change?
We can change.
Fortuna Castle.
Exterminate the defenders of the icy plain.
Alright, let me go to...
Mission menu.
And we shall change outfits.
Don't worry.
Don't worry about that guy.
The P stands for points, obviously.
Virgil jumpscare?
Who?
That's my brother!
That's my brother.
Sorry, wrong room.
What did you say about my brother?
That's not a who, that's my brother.
SBA stands for... that's right, super badass, a ghost.
Wait, it stands for... SBA stands for super badass?
Super badass?
Exterminate the defenders of the icy plain.
Why is it suddenly icy?
You got blue Dante?
Blue Dante.
So do you think Dante is cherry flavored and Virgil is blue raspberry flavored?
What flavor do you think Nero is?
I imagine him to be a grape flavor.
Like a mix between...
blue and red.
Dante is cherry.
Nero is a lemon.
Lemon lime?
You think lemon instead of grape?
I see Dante more as cola than cherry.
I can't exp...
No, no, no!
Swiftfish?
I get it, actually.
I get what you mean.
No, no, no.
You are onto something.
Dante being cola flavored makes sense, actually.
No, I get it.
Cherry cola!
Yes!
That's so good.
Nero is Pepsi?
Wouldn't Virgil be Pepsi?
Anyway.
Power up?
I don't think I can get anything, can I?
Well, I guess...
Yes, we can!
A dramatic display of power.
Flush.
Transform simple jumps into damage dealing attacks.
Let's try it.
Wait, so this is just...
This is just a stinger.
Oh my god!
I wonder what flavor mint would be.
Who knows?
No one tell him.
No one tell him, guys.
Whoa!
Oh, I made it!
I made it to the top!
I just realized we don't have Nero's little glowy arm anymore, so we don't know what secrets are around.
Wow, this is crazy!
Oh, I can do this one!
Wait.
There we go.
Okay.
Actually, I didn't check out what that was before.
I don't actually feel like doing that.
I'm sorry, guys.
I don't know why I'm so lazy today.
I think it's because I woke up so early.
I'm just quite lazy today.
I'm sorry.
I also did a lot of cleaning, so I'm just like...
Ah!
Oh!
That seems...
Yeah!
What is that reaction?
Oh my god, his lightning speed.
This guy is insane!
Oh my god!
Oh my gosh!
What the hell am I supposed to do with you?
Oh my god!
Oh dang it!
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
He's insane!
I think maybe my sword might be better here.
Oh my gosh, maybe not.
He's not electricity anymore.
Electricity out of him.
Oh, nevermind.
Uh-oh.
I spoke too soon.
Oh shoot!
Oh my god.
I'm trying to dodge him.
Oh, okay.
Does he even absorb this?
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm gonna die.
I'm actually gonna die to this guy.
I think I've just been taking damage this entire time.
No, I'll just redo it.
Oh man!
Oh my god!
Gunslinger, use your gun until you stun Gilgamesh.
Yeah, I think I was like thinking I was damaging him, but I was just taking damage.
Because you touch him and it's like so bad.
There we go, Gunslinger.
What the heck?
He's really cool though.
Oh my goodness!
Oh my god!
Even then I can't dodge.
Oh my gosh!
Maybe I switch... Oh no.
Oops.
Where is he?
Let's just spam I guess.
Okay,
and then...
No, no way.
No way.
Oh my god.
Oh no, please.
Shoot.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please!
I'm abandoned all hope real.
Oh my god.
This is insane!
This guy is just the real skill check.
He just comes out of nowhere.
I was just like, oh by the way, are you good at the game yet?
And he also... It takes so long.
Maybe... Okay, let me switch to Evony and Ivory.
We're on Gunslinger.
Oh my god.
He's so crazy!
He takes so much...
Ouch.
I thought I dodged that.
Oh my god.
Okay, fine.
Thank you.
Fine.
Ouchie ouch.
I wanna see if I can just get him like...
Oh my god.
Oh please.
There we go.
No,
no.
Okay, nevermind.
I think I know what to do.
Please, don't recharge.
Please...
No, no, no, no!
No, no, no!
No, please!
Please!
No!
Oh, I killed him.
He killed himself actually.
Just screaming for my life.
Blitz is my favorite demon in the entire Devil May Cry series.
Especially when I'm fighting him as Nero because the buster for Blitz looks so cool.
I have to fight him again!
No!
Don't make me!
I see you.
The floor is completely shrouded by the ice wall.
Reaching the door to return to town is an impossible dream.
To destroy this magical barrier of ice, it must be stopped at its source.
Oh well, where is that?
Okay.
This is the roar we've been wanting to get.
Does it...
Oh no!
How icy are we talking?
This one is open.
13...
Kick 13 has an enhanced version and D2 likes Stinger.
Oh, thank you.
I'll try and...
I feel so fast with my sword so that's why I use it more often.
But...
I'll try to...
use it too.
Oh.
Wait, I can't...
I can't defeat this guy?
Oh, I can!
I just missed every time.
My aim...
Nice, nice.
Yeah, get those...
Get those...
Grorbs!
I can't do this one anymore.
So sad.
Can I hit the mirror?
Oh, I didn't even notice that right there.
Good to know.
Cool, cool, cool.
No Beyblade.
No Beyblade!
Let me see where I'm at in terms of...
skill.
Wait, no.
Styles, there we go.
Yes, yeah.
Upgraded Trickster all the way.
And Swordmaster, we're...
close-ish.
I guess I... What does Trickster give me?
Wait, no.
Oh, that's right.
I like Teleport.
I guess I can refund it and try with Swordmaster instead.
TP.
We'll try this.
Why not?
Swordmaster.
What's in here?
I guess this is where I'm supposed to go.
Oh, it's you guys!
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm scared of you.
With my fists?
Oh no.
Oh my god, wait.
Wait.
Please, let me move.
No.
Can I get the other guy, actually, please?
Like, this guy, yeah.
Ouch!
No, I'm stuck on the wall.
I'm using this as an opportunity to learn...
Gerugumish.
There's another one.
Oh god, okay, I'm gonna DT.
Run!
Holy moly!
These guys are difficult.
These guys are so tough.
I don't like it.
I'm a sticker!
I really appreciate being able to fly across the room.
In such a way.
Ouch!
I've become reliant upon...
upon my sword.
Nice.
Oh, that was a good one.
Okay.
Yeah, I forgot about my sword master.
What was it again?
Is it just that I...
Is that what I unlocked?
While on the ground, press...
With a rebellion equipped, press...
RB back plus B.
They're executing...
Oh wait.
While on the ground...
Creepy music.
While on the ground with a rebellion, press B plus Y.
After executing a drive, press B immediately after...
Back...
And then B again.
Wait, I...
I'm trying, hold on.
There we go.
Like that.
Oh, I was too slow.
Okay, okay.
Nice.
Okay, what else was there?
Don't play fighting games.
I don't remember combos.
I'll try the same but forward instead.
That's just...
Oh wait.
Sorry, the camera got all of me.
Get out of here.
Yeah,
easy combo.
This is easy.
And it seems powerful.
Thank you.
Okay, so back...
Wait.
Okay, alright.
I think I can do those.
Stinger plus combo, yeah.
That's good.
Real impact was that.
Nope.
While on the ground...
Oh, this is Gilgamesh.
Real impact.
That's like a crazy uppercut.
Real impact destroys?
Is that why you guys were saying that Gilgamesh is so good?
I just didn't know the secret technique.
Let me try it.
Wait.
Like that?
So only the full move you actually hit.
Okay, but I am...
Before I am executing it.
Where did I come in from?
This is nothing.
Is there anything up here?
What's here?
I can't see.
It's so dark.
Okay.
And this was the...
The Roarb statue.
Is there anything down there?
Maybe?
Oh yeah, there was.
There's also a secret.
Real impact the shorter you can can hit an extra time if you double trigger while you're raising a punching.
This does wildly huge damage.
I see.
You see when that hits and you do like four times...
You guys love this move.
What is this one?
Let's see.
Eliminate all enemies without taking damage and without being captured by a fault.
Sounds boring.
Okay.
Where are we?
I'm in the mirror.
Oh wait.
Where are we?
Hold on.
I'm gonna go back out real quick.
Not because I'm lost.
But because...
I'm lost.
Okay, we came from over here.
Oh that's really it.
Okay, nevermind.
I guess that is where we need to go.
Okay, my bad.
Whoa!
I hope you guys don't have motion sickness.
What the hell was that?
Canoli.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
This was... Okay, I thought we were in a different area than where we were at.
Please...
So that's why I didn't go through.
Oh, makes sense, makes sense.
Why can't I just punch it with my fist?
It's just ice.
It's magical ice.
Yes, regain health and gather orb.
Regain health, gather orb.
Wait, so if I...
Oh wait, uh, nope.
I missed the chair.
Punch it.
I think it's already lit up, no?
Yeah, it's already lit up.
Let's check out here.
It's been awfully quiet.
What the heck?
I'm Spider-Man.
Pardon, welcome to Bamboo Ship.
Thank you.
What is this?
To proceed further, the power to repel fire must be...
Oh, that's... Yeah, yeah, I got that.
Okay, that's what this room is.
Okay, okay.
Yes, thank you.
I'm a little lost.
I'm just a tiny tad bit lost, guys.
I wish I could make Dante's hands into like giant hands.
They hit everything.
I did it!
No, no, back.
I did that too.
I'm doing it!
What the hell is that?
Wait, what is that?
What is that thing?
That's really big.
Wait, what are you?
What are you?
Come
on.
Come on, Dante.
Do it.
I think I did it.
Nice.
It's hard for me to time it sometimes, but...
This thing's big.
Wait, what was the other thing we did?
What was the other thing I learned?
Other...
I'm not good at like time...
There we go.
Sucker!
Oh, it was the sword move.
That's right, it was the sword move.
Thank you.
I like this one now.
Happy to see you enjoying Gilgamesh.
Let's get all these rawr.
Nice.
Get everything off the table.
It's clean now.
Yeah, I like that move.
It's kind of hard for me to get the...
part of it though.
But I'll work on it.
I'll work on it.
Oh, we're on the other side.
Lovely.
I was going to say, do you think it's in there?
But it does not seem to be.
Or maybe it is.
I don't know.
I'm not a doctor.
The other uppercut move.
I'm getting my uppercuts all mixed up.
There are two.
How do I know if I'm doing one or the other?
Or rather, how do I...
differentiate with my fingers?
Okay, so not through here.
And not down here.
So we'll go in that other door.
Hold the button.
I see.
I was going to say, is this room...
I know this room always has enemies.
The torture room.
Wait.
Jump.
Hold on.
Oh, I did that instead.
Ah.
Ouch.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I think I'm too... I feel too slow.
I'm trapped.
I'm trapped in here.
Wait.
Yeah!
Jump away.
Get out of here.
Except he didn't do that.
Okay.
Let's try now.
Oh.
That was unfortunate timing.
Wait.
It's a work in progress.
We'll get there.
Do I go down?
Or do I go...
There was a... I think it's the room...
Is up.
You're doing it?
I am?
You think so?
Down is the way up.
Button mashing goes intense there.
Truly.
Okay.
Do I just... What does this do again?
Oops.
Wait.
Yes.
This is what I was supposed to do.
Okay.
No parkour.
We're too good.
Wait.
And then this lowered.
I do remember that.
And there's the torture area down there.
I'm trying not to fall.
Okay.
Yeah.
Because we lowered that with that thingy right there.
No!
No.
Show them your new moves.
Yeah.
Ugh.
She has PTSD already.
It's like the one guy that has taken me multiple lives to kill.
One second.
I've been sitting on it.
So I got a bracelet in the mail.
I thought it was cute.
So I bought it.
But it came all crinkled.
Because it's like a PVC.
So I've been sitting on it.
And I sat on it wrong.
I sat on it wrong.
It became more crinkled.
Whoops.
He is lightening the rain transform.
I don't want to play Raiden.
Is it still wearable?
Yeah.
I fixed it.
Or I will fix it.
I'm just sitting on it.
It's better than it was when I first got it.
We're obsessed with you.
I know.
No.
I'll buy that bracelet.
It's my bracelet.
I'm just sitting on it.
Because it's getting nice and toasty.
Just sitting on it.
Uncrinkle it.
Yeah.
Because it's like a plastic.
And so I've been sitting on it.
I've been heating it up with my bum.
Okay.
I'm plastic.
It doesn't poke your butt?
No.
You can't buy it from me.
It's my special bracelet.
Why would I sell it if I bought it for me to wear?
I'm a bird.
It's my little egg.
I'm waiting for it to hatch.
Okay.
I'm not stalling or anything.
I'm just, you know...
Okay.
I'm gonna try and take out those other guys first and then we shoot the other guy.
Oh god.
No.
Please.
Go away.
Please go away.
There we go.
Okay.
That's one guy taken care of.
Where's the other guy?
He's right there.
Ouch.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
I can't read his moves yet.
Even though I fought him multiple times.
Bloodslinger.
Where are you?
We're also gaining D.A.T.
Please.
Okay.
There.
Sword.
No.
Please.
I'm bad.
Oh no.
Please hold on.
Please.
I think I messed up you guys.
No.
Oh gosh.
Oh god.
I messed up.
No.
Oh gosh.
Please.
Okay.
I'm just gonna...
No.
Please.
Please leave me alone.
No.
Leave me alone.
Please.
Please leave me alone.
Ouch.
I'm on Royal Guard for some reason.
No.
Please.
Leave me alone.
When in doubt, play like you're playing DMC2.
Oh gosh.
Yeah.
Time to go back for that grurb, huh?
Golly.
Please.
High five.
Oh my god.
My favorite part is when you start playing on hard and these guys start popping.
But it's only stage 3 and you have to fight two of them at the same time.
I could never.
Thanks for all the silly noises.
It's not on purpose.
Should I go back for the grurb?
Should I go back for it?
Yes.
No.
You have plenty of health.
So true.
Look at that grurb up there.
He's huge.
Wow.
Time is beautiful, isn't it?
OK.
Just don't get hit.
Please don't be another guy.
No.
Maybe there's some grurbs in here.
The death brings us life in terms of...
See?
They bring us life from their sacrifice.
Oh wow.
I was gonna say there's gates here now.
Yeah, I didn't do that one.
I'm getting pops and turvy.
I like just destroying the furniture.
Grurb.
Please.
Won't someone spare me just a little bit of green?
Wow!
That's a big green!
Yeah, let's go baby.
Is that a yorb up there?
How do I get to it?
How do I get to that?
Good thing I didn't go all the way back.
Oh, can't destroy the tree.
How do I get to it?
Oh wait.
One more statue.
I have full health.
Let's go.
Take some skill.
Yeah, I think I have to do the... Can I DT?
I have no DT.
Where did my bracelet go?
I found it.
Two stars as well.
I only see the yorb and the rorb.
There's stars up here even?
I kind of want the yorb.
I already have one, but I think it might be good for a boss battle.
I don't know.
Devoured by my huge Oshiri.
Why would you say that?
Why would you say it like that?
I wonder if this area... Oh my goodness, camera please.
You're really not helping.
It was this one, no?
I had the secret.
I remembered.
Did this one have a secret too?
It did!
Why would you read that?
I like reading.
Why are you victim blaming here?
It's more like, why would you write that?
Why are you blaming me?
I'm the one...
You're like, hey, why did you read that thing about yourself?
Why did the person type it?
I meant to love you.
Hello!
Thanks.
Devil stars maybe?
I'm so close to a final porb though.
I'm so close to the final porb.
I wish I could... Oh I have zero.
I have one M star and one L star.
Actually, I don't think I need to buy any.
Those are some devil stars.
I have two devil stars.
Small.
Two holy waters!
Holy moly!
Hi Mito, I see you as a little sister.
Hi Mustacheman, I see you all over YouTube.
Little sister.
Hopefully you're not a brocon then.
Imagine it's like, I just see you as a little sister.
And I'm a brocon.
I actually prefer that.
I prefer if you see me as like, you know, a sister.
Or you could see me as one of your homies.
As just a bro.
We're just hanging out.
We're just the bros.
Oh yeah, I would be a siscon.
You're right.
You're right, you're right.
Or...
Actually, what if they're just like, I see you as my sister and I am a brocon.
I wish you were my brother.
I wish you were...
Is that you?
It's complicated.
You have such complicated feelings, right?
Oh, it's so sad.
I always wanted a brother.
Because I'm a brocon.
But honestly, I did always want a brother.
I only have a sister.
And my sister is mean.
And I wanted a big brother to protect me.
Brother-in-law.
Who am I marrying?
Okay, whoever I marry must have a brother.
I guess.
Okay, let's save up for the final porb.
50,000 porb.
Craziness.
How much?
How many fragments do I have?
3 out of 4.
We're close.
Oh, it's stinky in here.
Smelly.
Woman smell.
It's a big fish man.
Good morning, my brother.
Big brother expectations protects you.
Big brother reality sits on you in parts.
I always see you as my brother.
Dante is into it.
Miro is just... Oh my god, he's...
Oh my god, he's literally interpretive dancing for them.
This is beautiful.
Jump!
So true.
Say it, don't spray it man.
Oh,
nasty.
Oh, I'm frozen.
Shot
you.
Awesome.
To build some DT.
Get
real close.
Get nice.
Use Gilgamesh DT for one hit?
Really?
It's time for sexy lady time.
But I don't want them to catch me.
Nice, they give a lot of roar.
Oh no!
I got caught.
He's chomping on me.
Where did he go?
Sexy.
Which I would never say most of the time, but...
You know, this is a specific circumstance.
Stay away, sexy.
Don't touch me.
DT to escape.
Oh, thank you.
How does he make that really pretty laugh?
You have such a nice laugh, madam.
Stay away from me.
At least I'm doing... I'm doing some damage.
Oh, wait.
Uh-oh.
I'm not anywhere close to him.
Oh, there we go.
Wait, there we go.
That could have gone better, but...
That could have gone better, but I did some good damage.
I keep doing the wrong move.
Yeah, because I'm panicking.
I'm a panicker.
Oh, there they are.
Hello, lady.
Can I do this here?
Wait, I did the wrong thing.
Oh, wow, that actually worked.
I can't DT.
This sucks.
I messed up.
I should have just done what I was doing before.
I really screwed that one up.
And he gains... Wait, is he regaining health?
Or am I crazy?
No?
Okay.
Where's the other lady?
Where are you?
Oh, I saw you.
Stinger, my beloved!
Is he gonna come eat me?
She wishes she could though.
I won't let you.
Okay.
Sexy lady.
Trying to gain some...
Oh my goodness.
Here we go.
Dang it.
Oh my
gosh.
I'm not doing it right.
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
I can't DT.
No!
Don't eat me!
I at least finished with that combo.
Combo combo.
Yeah, I get styled on.
Yeah, I could at least finish with that.
This guy, I think, was not as bad as the other sexy lady.
I love that YouTube font of the sexy lady.
Oh wow, big briefcase.
I'm going to work.
It's Dante's...
Salaryman era.
What?
Oh yeah, these guys.
There were more of them, weren't there?
Oh no.
This doesn't stop!
What is this?
He's gyrating.
Oh my god!
What the...what is this?
It's like a gyroid.
What?
Wait.
A demonic weapon capable of 666 calamitous forms.
It spells misery and disaster for countless foes.
While on the ground, press X.
Transform Pandora into a bowgun capable of firing ravaging projectiles.
Successful attacks will increase the disaster gauge.
If you're using gunslinger mode, you can do all of these moves.
It's great, if confusing to learn.
What?
Change the weapon's form by entering a transformation code while holding X.
How do I use it though?
How do I shoot it?
Oh wait.
What the?
Oh, just like that.
I just let go.
Oh, interesting.
Oh my god!
Wait.
Is it under sword?
What is it under?
Stability?
Yesterday was my birthday, but I didn't have time to watch yesterday's stream.
No problem, Ren.
I'll be honest, I wouldn't have been able to sing you happy birthday yesterday anyway.
So I can sing you happy birthday today!
One more time!
To the both of you.
Do I just leave?
I hope so.
Oh yeah, because we gotta get through the...
Now all the ice should be gone.
Happy birthday.
Next.
It's a bad time to say my birthday.
Why are so many people's birthdays on April Fool's?
You're a Lian god, is that how you say it?
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Lian god!
Happy birthday!
Mission 16.
Return the Conqueror of the Fire Hell back to his domain.
Is this another boss?
One second real quick.
There we go.
Is this another boss?
Yup, Nero's first boss.
What was the first boss we did?
I'm trying to think.
So the Pandora codes are just moving the analog stick while holding X then releasing.
You'll realize because you'll see the weapon transform.
Let's check it out I suppose.
Pandora.
While holding X, move L, S in any combination of left or right three times.
Revengeance.
After executing hatred, spin L, S twice in any direction.
1, 2, 3.
So I go like 1, 2, 3 and then...
Left, right, left.
And then spin.
Wiggle that stick.
I'm good at that.
I can do it.
We can try it.
Let's buy it.
Why not?
Oh my gosh, we are so close to...
Did I get any orbs for beating the frog?
I don't think so.
We got scammed.
Left, right, left, spin!
It's very good for a specific boss.
It said specific boss.
Coming up.
I only have 16.
I think...
I was... no, not round trip.
I was going to do maybe...
Styles.
I was thinking of upgrading trickster, but it's ok.
Did they get more expensive?
I thought I remember it being 5,000.
Ok, mission started.
I'm gonna try it right now.
Oh, great.
Yeah, great.
Oh, no going back up I suppose.
They get more expensive the more skills you get.
Ah, skillflation.
Oh, the stinky room.
Oh, smells bad.
Oh, it really is.
A poisonous gas permeates the air.
You must escape before your life is drained.
Oh, there's more.
No!
Oh, shoot.
It's these guys.
I don't think I even hit one.
Oh, I can't move it.
Oh, you better just hope that...
Ok, this is not working.
I wish I could grabby-grab these guys.
This sucks.
Oh, this sucks.
Oh, shoot.
Oh my gosh.
My life!
Get a little roar.
I fear I must... Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I fear I should get closer to...
Oh my goodness.
I'm not good at this.
Please die!
Shotgun is better.
Oh gosh.
Why is this so bad?
Why am I so bad at this?
There we go.
Oh my gosh, finally.
Please no.
Please get that creature.
Why am I so bad at this?
Hold on.
I
don't like this at all.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna die you guys.
I'm not gonna have to redo this part.
Oh, this sucks.
I don't like it.
Please come out of the water.
Please come out and not like that though.
Yeah, I'm dead.
Oh, no.
This part sucks.
We went this way.
Where do I go?
Oh, never mind.
This way!
DT stinger should pop them out of the water.
It should?
I don't have much DT, but...
Okay, that's one.
Okay, I'm running.
Wait, all my grorbs are gone.
Wait, this sucks.
This sucks.
Oh, no!
No!
Somebody
in ivory.
Wait, some people said that the shotgun is better.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, no.
Wait, get that guy.
Get that guy before he goes back in the water.
Okay, that's another guy.
Nice.
Where did he go?
Hello?
Please come out.
Oh my god.
I hate these guys.
I miss Nero.
Dante!
Please!
Please, let me out.
Let me out.
There we go.
Do you hate them more than the angels in 3?
I don't know actually.
Oh gosh.
No, not this again.
We say enough with your nonsense.
I can't grab it.
I can't.
Oh, but I can.
Kind of grab it.
Oh my gosh.
Ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
You know what?
Screw it.
Wait, can one of you plant into the ground again, please?
I got one.
Let's go.
I got two.
Three.
Ouch.
Wait, wait, wait.
I thought I was on trickster for a second.
Oh wait, I think I missed it.
Trickster, trickster, trickster.
There we go.
No please.
Ouch, I was trying to get that guy.
Do they ever stop?
There we go.
Yeah!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my goodness, please.
I'm gonna grab this roar.
Where are you?
Oh.
Come here.
Was that the trick?
Wait, could I have left at any time?
Oh, but what about the blue?
Wait a second, no way!
It was blue!
There was the blue!
Wait!
No way!
Nice.
No way.
I could have left at any time.
That's so stupid.
They tricked me!
Oh shoot.
At least my health is not doing so poorly.
OK.
It was a good red orb farm though.
Yeah, that's totally why I did it.
There we go.
We're so close to the last orb.
I can't believe I got bamboozled.
Actually, I can't believe it.
Maybe I can't believe it.
Donkey Kong?
Oh no!
We're back in!
Come on, seriously?
How dare they bamboozle me.
Wait, what if I...
Wait.
He's pretty good.
How did I start doing that?
What?
I'm not trying to do that!
Get me out of here!
I don't like this.
Wait.
I'm trying to... It's because I'm on Gunslinger.
I'm such an idiot.
I'm on Gunslinger.
That's why.
Please.
No, I'm too slow.
I'm too slow.
There.
Like that.
That's what I'm trying to do.
Golly.
You're too slow.
I was too slow.
This way.
Right?
Actually, which way?
Which way?
Wait, I'm lost.
Guys, I'm lost.
The map doesn't help.
Oh!
I see.
Tiny map doesn't help.
Big map...good idea.
Wait, so then I...
I go underneath.
Wrong way.
Yeah, I'm so lost in the sauce right now.
Call?
Wait.
The circular cage has a gap you can jump through.
That gap.
I'm so lost.
In here?
Ok, I do remember the...
Oh, come on.
You're welcome.
Damn.
Yeah, you wanna...
Why
am I...Oh, I think I need to hold it, right?
No?
I'm confused.
I'm so confused how to do this, though.
I am doing...Maybe it's because the camera...
Ouch.
Oh, come on!
Dante!
Dante.
Ok, I give up.
I give up.
Oh
my god.
This
is no longer pain...Oh, it is no longer painful to breathe.
Finally.
Painful
to breathe, says you.
It's painful for me.
Oh, we're back inside.
By eliminating its source, the magical barrier of ice has been melted.
Yeah, looks like you will be able to leave the castle now.
Yippee!
We're at 5,000!
Or 50,000!
Hold on.
Let's get our final orb.
I will have literally two orbs to my name.
Yippee!
Two orbs to my name!
KZU, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Nothing there?
Ok.
Oh, that's not what I meant.
There we go.
I can DT for like two seconds.
Here.
Ok.
We're gonna do it.
Was it worth it?
Maybe.
Mr. Matt Johnson, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Yeah, what's my disaster gauge?
It said that I have a disaster gauge since I got Pandora.
But it did not explain what it is.
The purple bar.
Yeah, I know.
But what is it?
What does it mean?
What does it do?
It fills using Pandora.
Yeah, I know, but what does it do?
It's for gunslinger moves of Pandora.
Ah, ok.
I see, I see.
La la la, I'm leaving.
Where's the heat guy?
How far away is he?
This is where we first met sexy Trish.
I'm feeling the heat.
Come here boy.
Oh, he just... Oh my god.
Oh, dog.
This is...
Oh, mini dogs.
I lost a lot of health though.
Twinkle dogs?
They wish.
They wish they could be twinkle dogs.
Diamond dogs.
Oh, they are all shooting at once.
Ok.
Alright.
I should probably fight them now.
They are so fast.
Ouch.
Goodbye.
Meow.
Tread Pandora.
But the thing is that... Oh, you can direct it like this.
But you can't move it side to side which kind of sucks.
DT singer is really the solution to everything.
It feels that way, huh?
Oh, this is where we came from.
My bad.
Okie dokie.
I know.
Stinger is really...
Such a lovely tool.
Such a lovely little trick they have given us.
Ah, yeah baby.
No more?
Stingy.
Pandora seems to have a big learning curve.
Perhaps.
Wait, is it not this way?
Oh, here.
That's right.
I remember.
I love backtracking.
Slippery.
More dogs!
Where am I?
Come here.
Come here dog.
Stop being so fast!
Oh, that's not at all where I should be.
These guys aren't so tough.
Can you tell they ran out of level by halfway through?
Don't fall off the edge.
Don't fall off.
Grab that roar.
Nice.
Do a flip!
Long level.
Wait, what's this way?
Open?
I like remember these areas and I'm also like...
Oh, see?
I remember going through here.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
What's up here?
Oh, we can't go...
Oh, look how cute!
Who's working down here?
Yeah, they existed.
Who's
still...
Ok, easy.
Easy Dante.
Nice!
Good job Dante.
Oh!
Oh no, that's not a roar.
This way?
But what is over here?
Oh, I think that's wrong.
Up top.
Up top!
And then what's over here?
Sword.
What's over here?
Nothing.
Exit.
We are so rich!
Oh no!
Wait!
Oh yeah, this guy!
Oh my god.
Wait, isn't the enemy of my enemy my friend?
No?
We can work together and get rid of that guy, no?
Oh yeah.
No, still enemy.
That's sad.
That does some damage.
Put your shades on, we got him.
Please.
Oh, I can't turn sideways everybody.
Absolutely nothing.
That's so unfortunate.
That's so sad.
That did nothing.
It actually did nothing.
Nothing.
I fired it at the ground.
Pandora is hard.
He was right in front of me.
How could I miss?
Let's actually play.
Let's actually fight.
Here we go.
I don't want you.
Let's build up some DT.
Is it only good if I hit his head?
Wait, oh shoot.
I should've...
Ouch, ouch.
Yes.
Come here.
I was like, I'm gonna regret this probably.
Ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
I think I dodged right into his socks.
He got me with his back legs even.
Damn it, I pressed the wrong button.
I'm so stupid.
Nice.
I did the wrong move.
I
finished with it!
I did it!
With
one bullet.
Hehehe.
I'm so proud of myself.
I was able to do it on the last shot.
On the last hit.
What is...
What is going on?
Ah!
Damn.
First I whip it out.
Wow!
I'm literally crying.
That was a masterpiece.
Wow.
In the end we are all satisfied.
He was talking about his sword.
Like with a sword, right?
I love so much that the game springs that on you and then expects you to go about your business.
As if it never happened.
I want to know what the...
I want to know what the room was like when someone proposed that.
You know, like someone went into work that day and was just like...
Okay, what if we just introduce this musical number out of nowhere.
Lucifer, a hellish...
A hellish weapon capable of summoning an infinite number of exploding blades that hover ominously in the air.
I love how in the cutscenes the power-ups are so cool, but then you actually use them and they are not as cool.
I get it.
Like I get it, but it's just funny.
No, it's so cool.
Wow.
I feel like I only want to use Lucifer because I...
Sexy Spanish guitar.
I know when the guitar started playing I was like where is this music coming from?
And then it was a full number.
From what I remember, all that stuff he said was improvised by the VA.
No way.
In JP too?
Every cutscene in this game feels like the devs are having a little too much fun.
You know what, that's the best way to make a game, no?
Nero is having the worst moment of his life and this guy is collecting weapons and messing around.
Nero is like dissolving into darkness.
Nero is dissolving into darkness with his girlfriend and here we are being like first time, whip it out.
Oh, JP voice acting didn't exist in this game.
I see.
That's even better.
Position swords around you and pierce your enemies repeatedly.
I like it's why why why why?
I assume.
What's the dot dot dot dot for?
Wait, can we see the big guy from here?
No.
It would be cool if we could see him.
Oh wait I'm still in DT, oh my goodness.
Always press Y.
Sorry, I turned it up because that song was so good.
Now taunt...
But...
Come on.
Is Nero dissolving that important?
Gotta have the right priorities.
So true.
Okay.
Up, up.
Wait, this way.
Wait, yeah.
I'll practice with it.
Oh my...
Oh, yeah, I totally beat the boss with that.
BAB!
Just a BAB.
Just a BABy.
Oh...
I think I might call it here, guys.
Next time we should be able to finish, no?
We'll have a few more missions left?
What?
This was...
This was 17.
Oh, hold on.
Mission...
If I go to next, let's see.
Yes.
That was Peak Cinema.
Have you played DMCV?
If not...
No, I'm going in.
I'm going in.
It's B.
Oh, like it's in Metal Gear.
No, I haven't played 5 yet.
I'm...
I'm going in...
Release in order.
So...
And this is my first time ever playing the series, so...
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
That was...
That was 6.
Oh, I thought we were...
I thought we just did 17.
So now we have 17, 18, 19, 20.
So 4 left.
I thought that was 17.
I'm all mixed up.
V...
V has come to...
Check Sword Master moves for Lucifer.
Pin up.
Throw multiple swords and position them in the air in front of you.
What do the swords do?
Do they just pierce?
Well, I'll buy it.
But I'll look at that again next time.
So, yeah.
We should be able to...
Which DMC has been your favorite so far?
I'm going to have to say this one.
I'm not going to lie.
Oh, so the explosion does do damage.
Woo!
Prince of Denmark!
I didn't want to distract you during gameplay, so I waited until now.
I just wanted to tell you how much I value hiding out in your livestream when I get the chance.
Thank you!
Thanks for hiding out.
You did say hiding, right?
Yeah.
I appreciate it.
You're going to love 5 then?
Oh my gosh.
My friends have been telling me that too.
They're like...
They were saying that most people are probably waiting for me to get to 5.
Because that's like the peak of peak.
No?
I'm so excited.
Oh my gosh!
I'm so excited to get to 5!
Are you planning on playing the reboot before 5?
Because it's technically released first, even though it's unconnected.
Probably not.
Probably we'll just go until 5.
True.
It's cute though.
It's cute.
I like Nero a lot.
I do like that guy.
He's my little baby boy.
The best way to end the stream.
You did some good gaming tonight.
Thank you!
I just want you to know I see you like a sister.
Questionable intent.
Oh no!
We got the sis card!
Wait, what if it's like...
I see you as a sister, but as in like a Maria-sama...
Maria-sama ga miteiru way of sister, you know?
Where it's like a holy sister.
And it's like...
Oh yeah, you're a sexy nun.
Okay, I've decided.
I'm going to do a nun outfit then.
And so then I can say you see me as a sister.
Like Mari from BA.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sister.
Holy sister.
Oh...
This was so much fun though today.
Oh man, we really got through a bunch.
So we have four missions.
How many missions did I get through today?
IDK if you're holy enough for that.
What?
I'm literally the holy...
I'm a holy spirit.
The manual for DMC4 had a little blurb about the characters.
And describes Kirie as both a sister and mother to Nero.
Yeah, sister as in a nun.
She is a sister.
She's a nun.
Mother?
I don't know.
Sister Minky, I'm here to confess my love for Kirie.
That reminds me of Fruits Basket.
Do you guys know Fruits Basket?
The anime manga.
I really loved Toru with Yuki.
When I first read it when I was a young wisp, I really liked Toru with Kyo.
And I never finished the series.
And then when I reread it slash watched it.
Actually I watched it, I did not read it.
I don't know why I said read it.
When I rewatched it, the remake.
I was like, oh my gosh, I really love Toru with Yuki.
And I know he's not like the guy she's gonna get with.
So that makes me so sad.
And then I kept watching it.
And for those who don't know, the reason she doesn't get with Yuki.
Is because suddenly midway through the season or through the series.
He's like, oh, I don't love Toru Honda.
I love her like she's my mom.
She got mom zoned.
And that makes me so sad.
I've never seen that happen before.
Especially in like a shoujo.
To get mom zoned.
Makes me sad.
I was like, because I was always just like, oh, I wonder, you know, what happens with Yuki.
Like, I really like him.
He's so polite.
And he's so cute.
And then...
And I was just like, oh, he's so good for Toru.
And then he mom zoned her.
And it's funny because she acts like a mom to Kyo.
So I'm just like...
It's honestly so funny.
Maple, that was my ship.
That's my ship and you say it's funny.
That was my ship.
Is my ship a joke to you?
Like Char and Char's counterattack.
Oh wait.
I have to watch Gundam.
Ships are serious business.
The ship sailed into the sunset.
And no, it didn't sail.
It actually, it docked.
It didn't sink.
My ship did not sink.
It docked.
At like a...
At like a port.
I love ending a bloodline.
This is a lot of fun.
So four missions left.
We'll be able to do it next week.
Yes, yes, yes.
I'm going to go eat dinner.
Thank you guys for joining me for more Devil May Cry.
And next week we'll beat it.
And then the week after...
No, not the week after.
I might give a little bit of time between...
Between starting five.
But it will happen obviously.
I think you'd like Gundam as an MGS fan.
Source, I am an MGS fan who loves Gundam.
I want to!
I want to get into Gundam.
What would you start with?
What should I start with?
Thanks for the one stream.
Thank you!
The ship docked at the mother base.
Watch Gundam.
Minto is pure, pure freak.
Oedipus!
Hey Minto, I see you as a mother figure.
No!
The original Gundam?
Start at the beginning.
OG Gundam.
Start with 00.
Is that OG?
Is that the beginning, beginning?
I want to watch the original too because of the new series.
The Geckos.
What's it called?
Watch Gundam in release order if real.
OK.
Thanks for the one stream.
Thank you!
The Gundam dock.
Yes, the Suisei one.
I see you as a father-brother figure that tries to kill me.
Let's go!
Anyway, thank you so much you guys!
I'm starting to get really hungry.
So I'm going to go eat.
And yeah, I will see you when I see you next.
Tomorrow I'm doing karaoke.
So if you want to watch some karaoke then come hang out.
Otsumito!
I'll see you guys later!
Bye bye!
Oh, someone eat something delicious.
Or actually everybody eat something delicious.
And then I'll possess you and I will have a delicious, delicious meal.